hey guys I'm Eric Voss and Rogue one a
Star Wars story has been in theaters for
a little while now now we've already
made a few other videos that explain
some interesting stuff that we notice
but let's face it like any Star Wars
movie Rogue one is filled with Easter
eggs and interesting history and Design
Elements and missable references to the
broader Star Wars universe and other
iconic films so just like last year's
epic breakdown of the force awakens here
is another for rogue one just think of
it as a rewatch of Rogue one with an
annotated nerd commentary because
everyone loves commentary right of
course you do all right let's get
started with the opening images so this
film opens with the standard a long time
ago in a galaxy far far away but unlike
other Star Wars films there's obviously
no opening
crawl now according to director Gareth
Edwards an early draft of Gary wit's
script did include a four sentence
opening crawl but the people at
lucasfilm said no because they wanted
Rogue one to be a standalone film and
not an official episode of The Saga but
the idea is that between the prologue
scene and the sentence in the opening
crawl of a new hope that that John null
based this whole movie on Rogue one
doesn't need an opening crawl we get
what's going on and at least this way
there's fewer giant Yellow words
littering the Galaxy that stuff piles up
guys but Rogue one still does have a
very classic Star Wars opening there's a
sudden orchestral
punch from Michael Gino and a shot of
space and then notice how the shadow on
the rings of lamu forms this gray
triangular shape and I'm pretty sure
that Edwards intended this to be a
mirror of the hull of the Star
Destroyers from the iconic opening shots
of A New Hope and of the Jedi so once
again here the Empire is descending onto
a fugitive trying to escape it Gareth
Edwards is kind of a wizard when it
comes to thinking about perspective and
scale and how we perceive massive
objects like the Death Star and Godzilla
and your mom right and repurposing these
visuals in interesting ways so I'll
point out more examples as we go okay
moving on to lamu and right away we're
seeing connections to A New Hope with a
moisture farm and blue Bantham milk and
this shot of gayen erso looking out at
The Horizon meant to reflect Luke's
iconic Horizon shot in A New Hope and I
think this scene of the Empire
terrorizing meager moisture Farmers is
meant to remind us of the deaths of
Uncle Owen and a baru everyone's
favorite charred skeletons giving Luke
and jyn parallel Origins they're both
Farm kids who lose their Guardians
forced to leave the farm behind but
while some elements of these two movies
are meant to be parallel there were also
some key decisions made to make them
inverses of each other so for example
notice the color scheme director krennic
is dressed in white by Black Death
Troopers now according to production
designer Doug Chang that is meant to be
a reversal from our first look of Darth
Vader in a new hope he wore black
flanked by white Stormtroopers and Chang
said that that is meant to reflect an
even broader reversal of this premise
with Luke being a farm boy who dreamed
of being a warrior versus jyn who was
forced into being a warrior at a young
age and dreamt of a normal home life and
let's talk real quick about the death
Troopers because the story behind them
is pretty cool the reason they're called
Death Troopers is that the original idea
was for them to be reanimated necrotic
flesh you know Space Zombies and some
concept art proposed for them to have
smaller or weirdly shaped heads to
suggest that they weren't fully human
but something between Droid and Soldier
now that's pretty crazy so ultimately
that idea was scrapped but they still
wanted to keep some of that inhuman
appearance for the death Troopers now
they realize that normal stormtrooper
armor makes actors look bulkier so they
intentionally cast taller leaner actors
for the death Troopers to achieve that
contrast and to reinforce a stereotype
that freakishly tall people have no
souls now getting back to Jen another
interesting reversal was her
Stormtrooper doll obviously meant as a
reference to reay's Rebel doll in the
force awakens I think this reflects
another concept that Gareth Edwards
wanted to explore in Rogue one the gray
area between good and evil in Star Wars
now in the past it's always been pretty
clear the rebels are noble Freedom
Fighters and the Empire are evil Space
Nazis but the fact that young jyn erso
would look at the Stormtroopers like gii
Jo's or Buzz Lightyear shows that from
the ground level before the Death Star
is public knowledge at least it's still
not totally clear who the good guys are
and we actually went into this in
another video but Rogue one really nails
that fog of War down to the details and
before I move on I want to point out
that jyn originally wasn't the main
focus of this movie in the beginning Jon
no proposed this as a streamlined
military Heist movie centered on a team
and for the pitch they edited together a
Sizzle reel using footage from Mission
Impossible and Hunt for Red October and
at the time NL titled the project the
destroyer of worlds then Gareth Edwards
reconceived the story with jyn as the
focus he also scrapped alternate concept
ideas of Jen's character like having a
little brother that she needed to
protect and the idea that her mom would
be a Jedi instead Edwards made her
focused on daddy issues with gayen Oro
the man who built the Death Star okay
let's move on to the Rogue one title
which floats back into space to join all
the other space litter and we also hear
composer Michael Gino's new rogue one
theme now I should mention that Gino
only had 4 and a half weeks to compose
this entire score as opposed to the full
year that film composers normally get
that's because previous composer
Alexander despla stepped down due to
scheduling conflicts during during
re-shoot now Gino previously stepped
aside from longtime collaborator JJ
Abrams to let John Williams do the score
for the force awakens instead Gino made
a cameo as a stormtrooper but even
Gino's rush job is still pretty
effective the score is 98% new with just
a few subtle moments where gioino
samples John Williams iconic Star Wars
music which I'll point out as we go all
right moving on to the introduction of
adult Jin erso played by Felicity Jones
now I should point out that this scene
in Imperial prison along with her rescue
and the introductions of Cassian and bod
were all among the scenes that were
added during re-shoot now the filmmakers
thought it would be pretty jarring to
jump from jyn's flashback as a girl into
the rebel interrogation where if you
remember in the first teaser footage JY
seems kind of sarcastic this is a
rebellion isn't it I Rebel is that clear
yes sir and all that was changed to make
JY more sympathetic more of a victim of
her circumstances and opening with JY
Behind Bars is a key part of her journey
in this movie so in addition to the
obvious theme of Hope Rogue one is about
characters transitioning from
imprisonment from feeling trapped to
making their own free choices going
rogue and fun fact the prequel novel
Catalyst explains that JY was born while
her mother and her father were in
political prison following a separatist
coup on their home planet of Vault so
really a life of incarceration is all
Jen really knows and I like how Gareth
Edwards starts this movie with dark
cramped claustrophobic shots of jyn but
as she begins to go Rogue her
surroundings begin to open up around her
which Edwards shows with increasingly
wider shots and real quick Jen's cthulu
looking cellmate is anen musters a rebel
prisoner the novelization reveals that
these two hate each other and she
actually threatens to kill Jen and the
next time they're out on the labor camp
so Jen broke out just in time to avoid
some anolin is the New Black drama all
right moving on to our first look at
Diego Luna's Captain Cassian Andor on
the Ring of cine now by the way this is
the first Star Wars movie to feature
titles explaining to us each new
location the editors explain that in
addition to not using the classic Star
Wars wipes they wanted to use
transitions to help give Rogue one a
standalone look now it was pretty
surprising to see Cassian as a
cold-blooded killer but the ultimate
visual guide explains that one of his
aliases is fulcrum now in the Star Wars
Universe a fulcrum agent is kind of like
a double O agent for the rebel alliiance
now this is from Star Wars Rebels where
fulcrum was a code name for ex Jedi
Ahsoka Tano so this makes Cassian more
of a James Bond Jason Bourne style
assassin and less of the friendly Rebel
recruitment officer that he was
described red as and the Spy whom
Cassian kills is named tivic and he's a
member of the partisans that's the
offret group of extremist Rebels that
saw Guerrera heads up we'll meet the
rest of them soon but quickly check out
the look of this trading Outpost Gareth
Edwards and the set designers modeled it
on the grimy underworld that we saw in
the movie Blade Runner which was set in
Los Angeles in the distant future of
2019 because that's only 2 years from
now again it all right let's move on to
jeda with bod Rook played by Riz Ahmed
we meet the rest of the partisans
including beaser Fortuna benic and edrio
Tu tubes and Mora now promotional
material made morof seem like he was
going to be a much bigger character than
he ended up being but the story behind
him was pretty interesting because he's
a relic of a different version of this
movie The Ensemble Heist version that
was altered during development so that
original team included a Duo named Senna
and lenck Senna was a large alien
creature who they imagined at one point
hauling a massive Imperial computer
perhaps containing the Death Star plans
and lck was a smaller buddy who hung out
on sena's shoulders who would like crawl
through air vents now lck was scrapped
completely and Senna went through
several redesigns before they settled on
[__] and ultimately the filmmakers
moved away from this original team
including other original members like
Dre nevas riala and jerus castal leaving
just Jenn and k2so and replacing the duo
of Sena and lenck with cherit and baz
maybe they felt sen and lenck were just
a little too similar to Groot and Rocket
Raccoon and the first Guardians of the
Galaxy or more likely the filmmakers
were under pressure to include Chinese
actors like Donnie yin and Jang Wen to
make the movie more marketable to
Chinese audiences and therefore make a
ton more money so big Hollywood movies
altering their scripts to appease the
Chinese film board is a huge complex
Trend that I'm not really going to get
into here but if you're wondering why
China saved the day in the Martian or
why Marvel changed a Tibetan character
in Doctor Strange remember this is a
business and billions of Chinese people
love Hollywood movies moving on to jyn's
rescue on wani which by the way is an
anagram for Obi-Wan don't anything to
say about that other than it's an
anagram now JY is traveling in an
imperial Juggernaut tank which you might
remember seeing in Revenge of the Sith
and we meet my favorite character in
this movie k2so congratulations you are
being rescued vo and performed via
motion capture by Alan tudk now
originally k2so was the Black Imperial
protocol Droid kind of like c3po's
cousin who's a former Nazi and you don't
really talk about it after several
redesigns they settled on a taller
Imperial Security Droid and TK's
performance is a big reason why k2o
works so great in Rogue one one he
actually has a lot of experience doing
comedic voiceover work and he
specifically voiced a robot with a
similar dry sense of humor in the movie
I Robot can a robot turn a canvas into a
beautiful
Masterpiece can
you now tudk also worked with the New
York mask teacher Orlando ptoy to learn
to express himself without using facial
expressions which is why so much humor
comes in physicality there are a lot of
explosions for two people blending in
right doesn't sound so bad to
me also apparently tudk improvised a ton
of his lines specifically when k2so
slaps Cassian where are you taking these
prisoners he is taking us to quiet and
there's a fresh one if you mouth off
again you can actually kind of see Diego
Luna smiling behind his hand there all
right let's move on to Yavin 4 and if
you look closely as Jen walks through
the rebel hanger you can actually see a
gonk Droid as well as a few astrom
droids which some people are saying are
R4 M9 and R5 X3 who have shown up in
other Star Wars movies but it's kind of
hard to confirm that exactly and as Jen
receives her assignment from the rebel
leaders we see genevo riy and Jimmy
Smiths reprising their roles as Mon
mothma and borana from Revenge of the
Sith we also see General Jan doana from
A New Hope now played by Ian melin AKA
sir barriston seli from Game of Thrones
and it looks like the set designers
built an exact replica of the Rebel
command room from A New Hope and it
wouldn't be surprised if George Lucas
just like keeps this set somewhere on
Skywalker Ranch like a poker room or
something now another interesting fact
about the scene is that according to the
editors the dialogue and the pacing of
the scene were based on the
interrogation scene with Ripley at the
beginning of the movie Aliens and both
of these movies feature strong female
leads reluctantly leading soldiers on a
space mission to redeem themselves and
prevent catastrophic destruction now as
Jen and Cassian depart we get a good
look at the rebel base and like in a new
hope this is filmed at Cardington sheds
in bedfordshire England which is a
former Royal Air Force hanger that is
now a film studio and the first Star
Wars production used the interior with
the exterior shots of the temple pyramid
being just like a matte painting but for
rogue one they did a full set buildout
both the interior and the exterior also
just like they did in A New Hope the set
designers reportedly use cardboard
cutouts of x-wings to fill in the
background of the Airfield but let's
talk about this new ship the u-wing the
u-wing was originally conceived to be
larger like the size of the Millennium
Falcon with a detachable smaller ship
that could go down to a planet's surface
then Gareth Edwards realized that they
just needed a transport size X-Wing for
the story now designer Doug Chang said
that he grew up drawing x- wings from A
New Hope and that he was super excited
to design a new ship that would be an
alteration on that with folding Wings to
imply that it was made from the same X
and y-wing manufacturer incom and they
went through hundreds of designs with an
alternate zwing and r-wing and Qing and
eventually settled on the u-wing modeled
on a catamaran basically they wanted a
ship that kids would want to pick up and
play with just like they would next Wing
just another reminder guys that this is
a business and it's all about selling
toys preferably toys that Chinese kids
kids would want to play with and if you
were wondering why we see so few u-
wings and why they don't really exist in
A New Hope and the other movies the
ultimate visual guide explains that the
u-wing was a new design from incom and
they only released a limited number
before the manufacturer was nationalized
by the Empire and Bale Orana was able to
get his hands on a few of them and
donated them to the rebellion and before
I move on I just love the detail that
went into the scene with the u-wing
taking off with G aino sampling John
Williams's Force
theme
and the inclusion of the Rebel Recon
officer from A New Hope who really has
the worst job in the Rebellion right
like you really couldn't put a Droid up
there that's got to be a punishment you
know okay moving on to this scene with
bod and saw Guerrera played by Forest
Whitaker Guerrera came from Gareth
Edwards desire to include a character
who was more of an extremist side of the
Rebellion like how in real wars
well-intentioned Freedom Fighters can
sometimes go too far and become
terrorists now the original concept art
was for the character to be a World of
Warcraft style troll creature but then
Lucas film VP K Hart suggested to use
sagrera who was a pre-existing character
from Clone Wars ultimately they made a
version of sagrera that was older and
crippled by years of fighting a lot like
Darth Vader and actually there's a
little detail that they added to
Guerrera here that ties him to Vader so
notice how when Guerrera stands over bod
and breathes from his mask you can hear
Darth Vader's iconic breathing mixed in
with the
audio now we don't hear that later when
Guerrera uses his mask and I think they
included it here to intimidate bod and
and Us by evoke Invader I swear when I
get older I'm just going to put an
oxygen tank in a camel back and use that
mask to scare little kids all the
time I can't wait to get close to death
all right let's move on to krennic and
Tarkin now I made another video about
the visual effects that went into
animating the likeness of Peter Cushing
and how actor guy Henry stood in with an
imitation of the character definitely
check that out but since then we've
learned even more about this process
with Henry imitating Cushing down to the
square shape he makes with his mouth ch
to the loss and the use of the special
motion capture headgear that synced up
Henry's facial movements with the
animation and I know some people are
still divided about whether it was
ethical to use the likeness of a
deceased actor like this so was it
Justified well let's let John null
explain he was the visual effect
supervisor who did all of these effects
this work was done with uh with great
affection and Care uh I'd like to think
that the role that we gave Tarkin in
this this film is one that Peter
krushing would have been really very
excited and happy to play ultimately I
think they were Justified because they
got the permission of the family and
this seems like an extremely costly not
at all casual process that was really a
one-time thing the original plans for
this station are kept there are they not
and yeah let's be honest it would be a
little confusing to see a story about
the Death Star becoming operational and
Tarkin not to be part of that you may
far when ready he'd have to like
conference call in or something and in
fact according to production if they
couldn't get the CGI right they
considered a backup plan of Tarkin
appearing via hologram instead you know
like Tupac and this whole spiteful
interaction between director krennic and
Tarkin here is meant to connect to the
Tarkin meeting scene in A New Hope like
krennic was originally based on the
white uniformed officer who sits at the
table and in that scene Tarkin has that
line about the emperor dissolving the
senate senate will no longer be of any
concern to us something that is a major
concern of Rogue one Tarkin if the
Senate gets wind of our project
countless systems will flock to the
Rebellion also a lot of people are
pointing out that that scene in A New
Hope had one empty seat at the table and
seat might have belonged to krennic now
Ben mendleson is an Australian actor and
he uses an interesting accent for
krennic allowing some of his Australian
twang to still come through one had
hoped that he and Lord Vader might have
been here for such an occasion I will
not fail now that contrasts the
traditional British accent that most
Imperial officers have including Tarkin
this bickering is pointless and it
suggests that kinic came from a
different background and had to work his
way up and has more of a chip on his
shoulder whereas Tarkin seems more
privileged and snobby now the shot of
the Death Star firing did dish lowering
into place was made specifically for the
trailer and concept art revealed that it
was originally part of a much longer
sequence that showed the dish launching
from a Mountaintop Lake on a hidden base
with thrusters lifting it out of the
atmosphere through space to the Death
Star and Gareth Edwards said that he
came up with the idea to use the shadow
of the dish by using a virtual camera
setup on an iPad from industrial Light
Magic and that allowed him to visualize
how these big pieces could move and at
one point he asks what if we added a
light here and the shadow that it
created inspired an entire vision ual
language for rogue one like in many of
Edward's best shots in this movie a
close-up of a shadow makes the viewer
wonder what it is we're looking at and
then once we realize it's a shadow of a
larger object it gives us a context of
scale this all gives Rogue one a
distinct look from the other Star Wars
movies and before I move on the visual
guide explains how the Death Star
project was Kept Secret all these years
so if you remember at the end of attack
of the Clones early construction for the
Death Star began on the planet Geonosis
and then once the framework was complete
the Empire sterilized the entire of
Geonosis wiping out a population of
billions just to keep it secret like I
mean I know they're bugs but that's
messed up that's like Starship Troopers
level messed up the only good bug is a
dead bug okay moving on to this quick
dream flashback of Jen and her parents
when they still worked for director
krennic now if you look in the
background that is corant this hints at
a much deeper backstory between the uros
and krennic from the Rogue one
novelization and Catalyst to quickly
summarize it Galen worked for krennic on
a corusant on Project celestial power
refining kyber crystals to create what
he thought was a new energy source when
really it was just for a super weapon I
need you to come
back come on do it kic we were this
close to providing peace and security
for the Galaxy you're confusing peace
with Terror well you have to start
somewhere so they fled with lra taking
this kyber crystal necklace with her as
a good omen and I have a theory on that
necklace that I'll talk about later now
we've talked about this before but this
is modeled on the real life physicist J
Robert Oppenheimer whose research on the
Manhattan Project led to the development
of the atomic bomb which he later came
to regret fun fact here Rogue one was
actually shipped out to theaters under
the code name Los Alamos which is where
the Manhattan Project research was
conducted now on Jetta this shot of
Cassian and jyn scoping out the plateau
was recreated from this concept art that
depicted Jetta as dirtier and more
industrial clearly showing the effects
of Imperial mining that's why when they
fly over the planet Cassian says this
line that's jeda or what's left of it
and if you look closely you can see a
new Imperial mining shuttle now
according to Doug Chang this shuttle was
modeled on Darth Vader's Lambic Class
Shuttle from Return of the Jedi but
instead of three folding Wings this one
has four and Chang wanted it to look
like an old Viking sailing ship that
when it comes at a dock all the ores are
rested straight up all right let's talk
about this scene with Bor gullet that's
the tentacle alien that s Guerrera uses
to interrogate people now the idea for
Bor gullet came from rder Chris whites
it's a telepathic spilop pod that can
understand exactly what you're thinking
and feed off your emotions and its whole
design with these absorbing tentacles
seems like a reference to the aliens in
Gareth Edwards earlier film monsters but
honestly other than verifying that bod
is indeed telling the truth about
defecting or as this movie's version of
the needle Droid on the Death Star in A
New Hope Bor gullet seems like kind of a
loose end toy now I think he had a
larger purpose to the story that was
left out in the final version of the
film my theory is that he was going to
interrogate jyn or maybe Cassian to
reveal that his true mission was to
actually assassinate galin or you know
maybe Bor gullet was just this movie's
version of a weird monster which exists
in pretty much every Star Wars movie or
maybe saw Guerrera uses Bor gullet for
like weird sex stuff Bor gullet when
will you come now the city of jedha is
filled with references to Star Wars
history there's this shiny ra7 protocol
Droid and a probe Droid from The Empire
Strikes Back I'm sure you all caught the
cameos by Dr Cornelius Evon and Ponda
Baba AKA walrus face from the mazis Le
Cantina in a new hope he doesn't like
you they don't like Jenny either and
other than it being kind of hilarious
that these two Planet Hoppers just pick
fights with anything that moves there's
actually a really interesting backstory
that explains why they're even on Jetta
right now so in the expanded universe
Evon is this crazy cosmetic surgeon and
originally he and pababa were named rufu
and Saki according to a 1981 radio drama
and the Rogue one visual guide explains
that a law man named Tam pusla is
searching for rufu and Saki which are
aliases for Evon and Baba for kidnapping
Force servitude and surgical alteration
to victims of terrorism on Jetta and
actually posla showed up in a shot from
the trailer along with this guy remember
him old Harry arms no head he was one of
their freak surgery patients along with
another concept element that didn't make
it in the final film The decraniated Who
are humans whose heads were shaved off
and turned into this cyborg servant
class so way to go Dr Evon and pababa
you two are even more human garbage than
we thought walrus garbage then Jen meets
Donnie Yin shered mway and Jang wns B
malbus and we get a few deep Throwbacks
to the earliest origin of Star Wars so
cheer at chance May the force of others
be with you which is an early version of
May the force be with you from a
previous draft of George lucas' script
for a New Hope also Cassian mentions
that these two guys are Guardians of the
wills it's Wills spelled w i l LS that
is a reference to the original title of
lucas' script which was the adventures
of Luke Starkiller as taken from the
Journal of the wills so Lucas conceived
the wills as race of wise alien beings
who founded the force as a faith and the
whole Star Wars saga is the Will's
Elders narrating an ancient myth from
their archives to their pupils which is
the origin of a long time ago in a
galaxy far far away of course George
Lucas decided that the audience didn't
really need this complicated framing
device so he dropped it but since Rogue
one is already so connected to that
Original Episode 4 story it's cool to
see the background of that story work
its way back into the films too now one
of the best things about the sequence
was the war imagery used by Gareth
Edwards and his team so when pitching
his version of Rogue one Edwards Used
real war photography from Vietnam and
World War II and Middle Eastern
conflicts photoshopping Rebel helmets
onto the tops of real soldiers and that
Vision influenced all parts of this
movie with the art Department modeling
Jetta on places like Jerusalem and the W
Rock of Jordan as well as Nazi occupied
Paris during World War II now the
cinematographer Greg Fraser shot Zero
Dark 30 as well and he helped bring this
gritty Vision to the screen notice the
framing and the slow buildup of this
entire sequence it seems like a
reference to another famous war movie
Saving Private Ryan which also features
a tank ambush in a
city and just like Saving Private Ryan
Rogue one aims to depict the whole fog
of war with Friendly Fire and children
caught in the crossfire the little girl
who Jen saves is named Pino the
novelization reveals she and her family
don't make it out of jeda City when the
Death Star attack comes she dies in her
father's arms and we learn that they
never even see the emerald light or hear
the thunder it's very sad almost as sad
as billions of genocided bugs on
Geonosis never forget guys and this
little badass is another partisan
fighter named We te Q he's played by
Warick Davis keeping in with the
tradition of playing Star Wars
characters with W names like Wicket the
Ewok from Return of the Jedi Wald and
weasel from The Phantom Min and Wan in
the first awakens now when cherit saves
Cassian and Jen from Stormtroopers I
just want to clarify again that he is
not a Jedi but he is at least low-level
Force sensitive despite his blindness he
could sense Jen's kyber crystal necklace
and the novel reveals that he knows
Cassian as a captain plus obviously he
Daredevils an entire Squad of
Stormtroopers so you know there's got to
be at least a few medoran bumping around
in there somewhere G just saying the
word medoran feels like vomit in my
mouth saurer is Hideout is another
location that's filled with Easter eggs
there's a non- hologram version of djar
which is the chess game that we saw in
the Millennium Falcon in A New Hope and
force awakens and actually think that
these game pieces are the ones used by
the production crew of the force awakens
to make those Holograms there's also
some softcore Hollow porn of a dancing
Twilight girl which we saw in Jabba's
Palace in Return of the Jedi also I
couldn't spot them but Gareth Edwards
said that the set designer slipped in
paintings of the creatures from monsters
and the mudo from Godzilla on the walls
in the background now notice this moment
when cheret tells Cassian there is more
than one sword of prison I sense that
you carry yours wherever you go that
connects back to the theme of
imprisonment that I mentioned earlier so
like jyn Cassian is trapped in his
position as Rebel assassin and he's
struggling with an urge to go Rogue and
make his own choices there's also this
fun little reference when Guerrera says
it's a trap which whiter doesn't really
deliver with any kind of wink but come
on you can't say it's a trap in a Star
Wars movie without it being an admirar
reference it's a trap I also appreciated
this line from Jen you can stand to see
the Imperial flag rain across the Galaxy
it's not a problem if you don't look up
now obviously this is flawed Thinking by
Jen like the Empire isn't a problem
normal people can just ignore like in in
fact at this very moment the Death Star
is about to Nuke all of them whether or
not Jen looks up I think Jen is
referencing the first moment she joined
up with saw back in that first scene
when she looks up at him in other words
Jen could be telling saw right now my
life would be better off without you and
based on Saw's H expression I think
that's how he takes it a give saw a hug
Bor gullet I said a hug said a hug not a
snug meanwhile on the Death Star you
notice the look of the Death Star
targeting screen I think that is modeled
on screens that show military drone
strikes with an overhead view and no
audio just a silent explosion and the
unsettling knowledge that you just
killed a ton of people oh it's beautiful
and fun thing to point out here the two
Death Star operators on the ledge by the
super laser are played by Ryan Johnson
and Ron Bergman who are the director and
producer of the upcoming Star Wars
episode 8 and they promis to let Gareth
Edwards make a cameo in that movie to
return the favor and these characters
must have also pissed off someone
important to have to stand right next to
a super laser with no railing kind of
like the rebel Recon officer of the
Empire pointless job now this moment of
anger between krennic and Tarkin is
super interesting because a Set photo
was recently released showing krennic
pointing a blaster at someone in that
location So based on the angle it seems
like it would be Tarkin so maybe at some
point there was an alternate version of
the scene that led to krennic drawing a
blaster on his Superior officer and
having to be talked down you may
not huh all right moving on to Edo now
the look at this planet is another
reference to the alien franchise the set
designers modeled the stormy Rocky
terrain on the planet LV 426 and then
along with the great Han Solo reference
that we got in the last scene punch it
punch it I really liked Cassian saying
that he didn't want to know well now
there's a 35% chance of I want to know
thank you I understand which seems like
this movies version of never tell me the
odds the possibility of successfully
navigating an asteroid field is
approximately 3,720 to1 never tell me
the odds now before we move on past this
edu section I want to pause on this
moment with Cassian aiming a sniper
rifle at galin on the platform so notice
the sound design as the raindrops hit
the metal of the
gun I think that this moment is another
reference to saving prev
Ryan now let's move on to the most
interesting location in this movie this
is Mustafar interestingly the only
planet not to receive a title which is
the same volcanic planet where Anakin
and Obi-Wan battled at the end of
Revenge of the
Sith so so why would Darth Vader build
his home in a place with so many unhappy
memories Vader needs to reinforce his
anger and suffering to keep him
connected to the dark side like moving
into the same building as your
ex-girlfriend the pain makes me strong I
I don't do that I'm not I'm not a
stalker but really the design elements
that went into this location are super
interesting they based the look of
Vader's Castle on sketches drawn by
Ralph McCory in the late '70s after A
New Hope which were to be used for The
Empire Strikes Back but were ultimately
left out the artwork showed a tall Grim
C castle in the middle of a lava lake
along with a mysterious lava Cavern with
a throne the designers began with this
vision and then fleshed it out into a
place that Vader could practically live
in and heal himself and meditate so they
used the back to Healing tank which we
saw Luke use in The Empire Strikes Back
and Gareth Edwards insisted on featuring
it so Gareth Edwards loved that brief
Glimpse that we saw of the back of Darth
Vader's head and Empire and he wanted
our first look of Vader and Rogue one to
be at his most vulnerable as an amputee
humanizing him just enough to Bal the
dark violent place he ends up in the
final sequence they also wanted this
place to show Vader as a true Sith so
not only is their Sith artwork on the
walls this entire Castle is in the shape
of a giant tuning fork which Edwards
described as Vader tuning himself to the
dark side it's also meant to be a mirror
opposite of the Temple of kyber on jedha
which has a similar look except it's
white one Temple for the light side of
the force and one for the dark and like
that temple on jedha Vader's Castle
might have ancient religious Roots as
well so designer Doug Chang conceived
the foundation of this Castle to be an
underground Sith cave and the Lava River
flows through it like a dam feeding the
castle energy so the theory is that
Vader chose this spot in particular to
connect his home to a site of historical
significance to the Sith and to build
his contribution on top of that and
really the fact that the creative team
has put so much thought into this makes
me think that we might see this cave
perhaps in episode 8 with Luke Skywalker
revisiting his father's past I don't
know we'll see anyway getting back to
Vader Edwards gives us this classic shot
of him using his iconic silhouette in
the sh shadow on the wall completely
enveloping kenic and naturally G Chino
samples John Williams Imperial March
[Music]
here also it's interesting how Vader
seems upset with kinic for destroying
jeda he claims it's because they risked
alerting the senate about the Death Star
but really I think Vader is just deeply
religious and part of him feels Furious
that this holy city and possible origin
of the forest was wiped out for a
demonstration of military power and
remember the last time an arrogant
officer bragged about the death star's
technological superiority this station
is now the ultimate power in the
universe hiden
for Vader's response was the same as it
is with kenic be careful not to choke on
your aspirations director more like
don't choke on your popcorn after that
hilarious
pun I'm sorry okay sorry I'm sorry it
was it was super funny and before I move
on a lot of people were wondering who
this hooded figure is like when the
trailer came out we speculated that it
could be Emperor Palpatine or maybe even
snoke turns out it's vonie Vader's
creepy assistant and caretaker who you
know like probably sniffs Vader's helmet
when he takes it off now some people are
saying that he might actually have been
one of the guys in the emperor's
Entourage and Return of the Jedi now the
council meeting on yav 4 gives us a look
at the full Rebel leadership now besides
ret Return of the Jedi it's pretty rare
to see everyone in the same room like
this both politicians and Military this
leadership includes the civil government
led by Senator man mothma along with B
Orana of alderon Noah jevel of uter B
basar of the talot sector and timra Pomo
of taus that's from the Knights of the
Old Republic games it also includes the
military High command including General
jodana General Draven blue Squadron
leader General Merrick and this awesome
new monari Admiral rtis now character
designer Neil scanland modeled rtis on
Winston Churchill borrowing the World
War II era British prime minister's
likeness and mannerisms along with his
General eagerness to fight I say we
fight and right after this scene you
might have heard someone call for
General culla generala pleas report the
now obviously that's a reference to Hera
from the rebel series implying that she
could have gotten promoted or it could
also be referring to her father Cham
sindula from Clone Wars also the new
character pal shows up here pal actually
appeared in the concept art for the
force awakens but they didn't use him in
that movie and they used him here
instead now I already talked about the
scene between man mothma and Bale Orana
in my other video that explained how
this movie's ending fits in with the new
hope but if you listen closely to Orana
at the end of this scene you can hear
him call for Captain Antilles Captain
Antilles C that's Captain RIS Antilles
the captain of the Tanta 4 we saw him
taking R2 and 3PO at the end of Revenge
of the Sith and he is Darth Vader's
first onscreen kill in A New Hope all
right let's move on to scariff and this
may just be a coincidence but the name
scariff sounds very similar to the term
skiff which is a military acronym for
sensitive compartmented information
facility it's a place that's used to
store classified military information
and with that Citadel Tower that's
exactly what Scarff is but before we get
to this planet we see these quick shots
of Jenn holding her kyber crystal
necklace now this thing has come up a
few times on lamu on Jetta and why is it
so important now it could be related to
the deleted scenes or maybe it's just
meant as a token for jyn's connection to
her parents but I have a theory that
goes way deeper so we know kyber
crystals radiate a supernatural kind of
energy they power lightsabers and the
Death Star super laser and cheer's
proximity to them definitely seems to
have left them with some special
abilities we also know from the
Skywalkers that that Force sensitivity
is passed down through family Bloodlines
so let's go back to lra erso jyn's
mother lra being a Jedi was scrapped for
the final film but I think the necklace
is a relic of that backstory it's
possible that wearing this kyber Crystal
still might have given lra low level
Force sensitivity a protective energy
which she then passed on to jyn like
noticed how shortly after lra gives away
the necklace she dies and then as jyn
wears the necklace she's able to barely
survive extreme close call until she's
able to squeak by and carry out the
mission that ultimately turns the tides
against the empire now we had a similar
theory for the force awakens with po
damaran the book shattered Empire
suggested that he grew up with this
Ancient Forest tree at his home given to
his family by Luke Skywalker and living
in proximity to that concentrated Force
energy might have made him a
ridiculously Good Pilot the same way
that this kyber Crystal could give Jin
Force sensitivity now you could call all
of that plot armor like these are just
the main characters so of course they're
naturally good at surviving driving but
I call it the force working in
mysterious ways giving each of these
individuals the slightest Edge against
the otherwise unchecked dark Forces that
take over the Galaxy but let's move on
to scary obviously several steps of the
Rogue one Crews infiltration mirrors
tactics from the other Star Wars movies
like using a stolen Imperial code to
sneak onto a planet which happened in
Return of the Jedi and of course
sneaking into an Imperial base in
Imperial disguise which happened in A
New Hope and the parallels to A New Hope
continue with cameos by a mouse Droid
and k2so having the same rotary style
scom plank that RTD2 uses to hack into
the Imperial database and then of course
k2so utters the line I have a bad
feeling about this that appears in every
Star Wars movie but Jen and Cassian cut
him off before he can finish I've got a
bad feeling about he quiet perhaps as a
nod to the fact that Rogue one isn't a
full episode in the Star Wars saga so
maybe they can't say the full line I
don't know there's also this fun banter
between Stormtroopers on the beach hey
did you hear the rumors yeah the t15s a
bit marked obsolete oh boy it's about
time for that this seems like a
reference to the small talk between
Stormtroopers on the Death Star while
Obi-Wan snuck around them you seen that
new bt6 but this connection goes even
further the t-15 is a predecessor of the
t16 skyhopper which is the ship that
Luke owned on Tatooine the one he used
to Bullseye wamp rats and Beggar's
Canyon you know the ones that aren't
much bigger than 2
meters meanwhile back at Yavin 4 we get
a few more cameos first there is an
easily missable Cameo by Chopper c110p
That's The Lovable a-hole astr Droid
from Rebels and then an even more subtle
Cameo by another Astromech Droid and
this protocol Droid whose names are
escaping me at the moment but they seem
to show up in like every Star Wars movie
so Random now the ground battle on
Scarff was shot with two major
influences the first was the movie The
Thin Red Line which is a War epic that
takes place in the Pacific in World War
II and that movie came out in the same
year saving priv Ryan and I think many
of these tropical beach shots seem to be
borrowing from that movie but also
Gareth Edwards loved the trench Battle
on Hoth and The Empire Strikes Back and
he said that when he went back to watch
the movie he was surprised that the
scene only lasted like 2 minutes so he
wanted to expand the Ground Battle for
rogue one another mix of World War II
history and past Star Wars films came
into the design of the new Shore
Troopers the designer said that their
look was a mix of the camo coloration on
the Scout Troopers from indoor in Return
of the Jedi plus part of the clone
trooper helmet design and finally the
color scheme of The Messer Schmid that
was a German World War II fighter plane
which had an Earth Tone base and
distinct splashes of bright colors and
for the short Troopers those colors
denote rank with blue across the
shoulders and collar for squad leader
and a blue chest plate and yellow Band
On The Gauntlet for captain and in
addition to World War II the Vietnam War
inspired a lot of elements in this
battle as well so the new Thai Strikers
were designed to be in atmosphere
Fighters that only defend the surface
with the wings on top that would create
a silhouette of the rotor Blades of a
Vietnam era Huey helicopter from a
distance also this shot of bis Stan
firing a mounted gun out of the
u-wing looks like it's a reference to
the get some scene in Full Metal jacket
get some M okay let's talk about the
space Battle Above the planet which is
up there as one of the best Space
Battles we've seen in Star Wars there
are cameos by a ton of familiar ships a
lot of people spotted the ghost from
Rebels making people think that there's
going to be a Rebels episode where we
see them in the Battle of scariff but
there's also the e76 nebulon B escort
frigate that's the ship that Luke and
Leia regroup on after Cloud City it's
also seen in the Battle of Endor there's
also the gr 75 medium transport which we
saw during the retreat from Hoth and
Empire Strikes Back also the visual
guide gave us some really interesting
background on the mon calamari ships
they're actually former mon calamari
buildings and city blocks converted into
these massive passenger transports they
all contained thousands of refugees
specifically rus' ship which is called
the profundity was previously part of
the monari city of nistula and bratus
was actually that City's mayor before it
joined up with the alliance Fleet and
all this gives us some context of why
Admiral akbar's Flagship was called home
one it was literally his home now my CGI
breakdown briefly touched on the came by
Red leader Garvin D and gold leader John
Vander and obviously these cameos
weren't animated with CGI but like
Tarkin and Leia they were created using
archive footage so Gareth Edwards and
his team went through the lucasfilm
warehouse and they found old film
canisters containing unedited footage
from A New Hope and they found shots of
the red and the gold leader and they
decided to include them as inserts also
gold leader actor Angus McInnis is still
alive so they were able to re-record his
audio over that old footage we also see
the blue Squadron of X Wings in action
fun fact about those the original
x-wings in A New Hope were supposed to
be blue Squadron not red but the blue
screen technology at the time interfered
with the paint on the ships and the blue
on the costumes so back with the first
film it was changed to the red Squadron
in fact you can kind of see this
coloring problem with r2's blue panels
appearing gray and black in the Trench
Run and speaking of that red Squadron
this battle specifically shows the death
of red five that's fine I need help
leaving the call sign red five vacant
for Luke to take it over in the Battle
of Yavin red five standing by we also
get to see a hammerhead Corvette which
might be one of the ones that princess
Lair stole for the rebellion and Star
Wars Rebels and it's fascinating to see
a ship used as a battering ram in a
space battle I feel like that's the
first in Star Wars battering rams were
something from medieval warfare like
armies would use them to bust through
the gates into a fortress and that's
what this battering ram does it smashes
into a disabled Star Destroyer colliding
it with another star destroyer and
sending them both busting through the
shield gate to open up this planetary
Fortress and in case you wondering if
any of the crew of the Hammerhead
Cruiser survived or if it was a true
kamakazi attack John null said that the
VFX team actually animated a bunch of
Escape pods blasting off the Hammerhead
at the last second but Gareth Edwards
thought it was too distracting so he cut
it out of the shot but if you look
closely as the two Star Destroyers go
down according to null all the lifeboats
are gone from the Hammerhead implying
that they initially survive this however
even though they made it null mused that
the pods would have just made it down to
the scare of surface just in time for
the Death Star super laser to hit so
yeah war is hell and back in the Citadel
Tower there's a few other references
worth mentioning here Gareth Edwards
said that he paid tribute to George
Lucas's first film THX 11138 and I think
we see that when Cassian has to use the
handles to extract a file from the vault
which is similar to a scene in that
movie also when Jen is going through the
file names she mentions one called black
saber now a lot of people are saying
that could be a reference to the dark
saber from Clone Wars it's an ancient
black bladed lightsaber stolen from the
Jedi by the mandalorians and later owned
by Darth Maul who is somehow still alive
but along with the ghost and Chopper and
general culla I just feel like these
references to the Animated Series
probably won't be anything more than
just references like both Dave filon of
rebels and Gareth Edwards said that they
don't really want any characters
crossing over or their stories building
off of each other so if it was
intentional it's just really meant for
the fans all right moving on to jyn and
cassian's Final Moments so with the
running metaphor of the Death Star being
a game-changing weapon of mass
destruction like the nuclear bomb I
don't think it was an accident that this
shot on the beach looks a lot like the
footage of the nuclear bomb testing on
the bikini at to islands in the Pacific
so this kind of brings it full circle
with the history but I love how Gareth
Edwards turns an image that should be
terrifying and kind of a downer into
something almost poetic and the reason
this feels satisfying is that Jen and
cassan have completed their Journeys out
of the prisons that they were trapped in
at the beginning of the movie Jen out of
literal prison and cassan out of the
prison he carried with him like the
opening images of both of these
characters showed them in dark cramped
places that reflected this imprisonment
and now they're in a wide open space
surrounded by light by the way I think
there's a good chance that this ending
was part of the re-shoot and I get into
my alternate ending theory in another
video but also concept art shows us an
image of Jen looking at the Death Star
plans in a whole new location implying
that they might have wanted her to
survive in a previous version of the
story also an ABC News special on k2so
included footage from what must have
been an alternate ending because it
shows Alan tudk in this moap suit
getting gunned down on the Sandy Beach
not inside the Citadel Tower and if you
look closely next to him that is the
body of Cassian and we know that an
earlier draft of the screenplay ended
with at least some of them surviving so
at least there was some version of Rogue
one that might not have been as dark but
obviously that wasn't the case in the
final film because this movie was
merciless to all of its main characters
it was as if millions of voices cried
out in Terror what about the theory that
jyn is Ray's mom I thought the Rogue one
crew was going to be the Knights of ran
and were suddenly silenced all right
let's move on to the very final sequence
and clearly Gareth Edwards doesn't like
people walking out of his movies early
because this was insane now there's a
lot of reasons it works so well but the
main one is that this movie stops being
Rogue one which arguably ended on the
beach and starts being a prologue to A
New Hope the editor said that while they
were reconfiguring this whole third act
sequence after the re-shoot they
realized that these Final Shots really
belonged in episode 4 because everything
about them fits better into that movie
so for example we see Darth Vader Star
Destroyer the Devastator which is one of
the first images from a new hope after
the opening crawl also the firing
sequence on the Death Star is almost a
shot for shot remake of the previous
sequence and even featured tarkin's
iconic line you may dance if you want to
you may leave your friends behind no
it's far when ready and the 3D depiction
of the death start plans looks exactly
the same as when jandon debriefed the
pilots before the Battle of Yavin we
also hear Captain Antilles telling a
crew person to check the Escape pods on
the Tanta 4 setting up 3PO and R2 to use
one of these to escape with the plans on
tattooing soon after and then of course
the final image of Carrie Fisher as
Princess Leia which is obviously
heartbreaking to see now that the
actress has passed away but thankfully
it kind of works as a tribute further
immortalizing her iconic role and and
reminding us of one big reason that we
all cherish the Star Wars movies so much
but it's not just the specific imagery
from a new hope that makes the sequence
work it's the whole feel of it the
Frantic cutting the intense action the
music which actually featured a repre of
The Imperial March as Vader watches the
tenta for escape and if you were
listening super closely Gino snuck in
another another more subtle version of
The Imperial March music during the
hallway sequence which you can only
really hear by speeding up all the coral
voices
[Music]
[Applause]
listen so the tone here is all perfect
perfectly tuned with the opening moments
of the first Star Wars and mostly it
just feels right to see Vader be Vader
like we've been able to relive Darth
Vader's brutality and comics and books
and games like Battlefront but looking
at the films I would argue not since The
Empire Strikes Back have we seen Darth
Vader be the truly menacing terrifying
figure that he was initially designed to
be like I don't at all fault Return of
the Jedi or the prequels for humanizing
the villain and exploring a tragic
sympathetic side to him but there's a
reason Darth Vader is considered the
best villain in movie history and it's
not because we feel bad for him it's
because we're freaking afraid of him
like he Force chokes his own men and he
murders Rebels without a second thought
and he can stop you in your tracks with
just the sound of his breathing like the
most basic bodily function evokes Terror
and you might have felt Rogue one is a
little slow in the first half and maybe
it's hard to connect to any character
besides the Droid maybe that's just me
because I can't process empathy but you
can't argue that when it comes to the
things we love most about Star Wars
namely Darth Vader Rogue one really
sticks The Landing okay that was a lot
of stuff even for a nerdy commentary and
I know I left some stuff out but we
actually covered a lot of this stuff in
our trailer breakdowns and really these
are just things that interest me as a
Star Wars fan and I'm sure we'll learn
even more about this movie as time goes
on and again make sure to check out the
other Rogue one videos we've done like
how Tarkin and Leia CGI was created how
the ending of this movie ties in with a
New Hope timeline and then my alternate
ending Theory as well as our argument
for why the lines between good and evil
in the Star Wars Universe might not be
so clear-cut and then also please like
this video And subscribe to new rock
stars because we make videos like this
all the time covering All Star Wars
content but also things like Marvel and
DC Game of Thrones Walking Dead
Westworld and if you do subscribe make
sure to click that Bell icon to turn on
email notifications for when our new
videos come out and if you really love
us you can also contribute to us on
patreon become a donor to help us get
even more videos like this out and of
course big thanks to all of our current
patrons and let me know any thoughts or
theories that you have down in the
comments you can also hit me up on
Twitter at eaos I star for attention so
there's a good chance I'll respond
especially if you're nice you can also
follow new rockstars on Twitter @ new
rockstars for updates for when our
videos are coming out all right thanks
for watching
[Music]
bye